[Música]
a questão toda a biologia não no
machismo pede mulher não foi feito para
se meter em chuteiras
o futebol não é compatível com as
condições de natureza da mulher que tem
ossos mais frágeis menor massa muscular
coração menor e respiração - apropriada
à sport pesados ao sexo frágil
algumas dessas frases foram ditas nos
anos 40 50 e 70
e pasmem algumas são ditas até hoje
algumas vezes pelo jornal mais
importante da cidade de são paulo
outras utilizadas para proibir o futebol
feminino na constituição
o futebol feminino ele deixou de ser
proibido no brasil em 1979 e com
deixar-se é proibido eu quero dizer que
as pessoas tenham liberdade de praticar
depois de anos de licença jogado quando
este estava clandestinamente
só que a regulamentação que ter regras e
condições só veio em 1986
alguns anos atrás olha quando tinha uns
10 anos de idade
eu estudei na escola que separava a
quadra no intervalo por dias da semana
a ideia que houvesse uma visão
democrática dos esportes e todo mundo
pudesse praticar o que desejasse
só que no brasil joga se muito futebol
então quase todos os dias a gente jogar
futebol só para as meninas conseguiram
entrar na quadra ou a gente ia invadir a
quadra
ou a gente é que implorar para os
meninos deixarem a gente participar o
que era muito complicado porque muitas
vezes os meninos eram fisicamente muito
maiores do que a gente e para o esporte
coletivo isso conta bastante
foi aí que surgiu a idéia a gente
decidiu fazer uma assembléia estudantil
o primeiro ponto foi entregue uma chapa
com a pena
um objetivo que era conseguir um dia da
semana só para as meninas jogaram
futebol ea gente conseguiu ameaçar o
ganhou e toda sexta feira meninas de
todas as idades e todas as salas subiam
e jogavam bola do lado de fora na
arquibancada ficavam os meninos como
deveria ser
ainda que os meninos tivessem mais dias
da semana
não era uma divisão igualitária era um
primeiro passo
a gente estava fazendo a ocupação de um
espaço majoritariamente masculino e
tornando aquilo não mais uma cota mas um
direito
a fifa publicou uma pesquisa em julho de
2019 que disse que o brasil tem 15 mil
mulheres jogando futebol de forma
organizada com forma organizada eu quero
dizer disputando um campeonato ou amador
ou profissional
só que esse número é um absurdo quando a
gente descobre que os estados unidos
tetracampeões mundiais têm 600 vezes
mais
são nove pontos 5 milhões de mulheres
jogando bola por lá na argentina sun 27
mil na venezuela 24 e até países com a
população infinitamente menor como
irlanda peru namíbia tem mais mulheres
jogando futebol do que no brasil
só que é uma questão pra mim eu acredito
que o auge do futebol feminino amador do
brasil
ele é na universidade que é uma coisa
quem é que joga ou já jogou futebol
pois é eu posso apostar com vocês que
pelo menos uma vez você já foram
convidadas a completar um time masculino
porque faltou um cara que não porque
você estava jogando bola com eles ea
faculdade é justamente aquele momento em
que você pode jogar com meninas porque
existe uma organização porque eu falo
que é o auge em premiação tem treino
toda semana
a estrutura coisa que a gente não tem no
dia a dia as meninas crescem jogando
futebol
quase que solitariamente porque elas só
podem entrar em um time que tem meninos
escolinhas que tem meninos campeonato
que tem meninos e aí foi na faculdade
que a minha história se uniu de vez o
futebol quando você sai da faculdade
você não tem mais onde jogar
e para a maioria das mulheres é aí que
acaba o futebol
então quando eu saí eu cheguei pra uma
das minhas amigas que jogava no time
falei ó agora que a gente não tem mais
onde jogar
vamos ter um dia na semana nosso a gente
vai se reunir e não faz por obrigação
que ganhar um campeonato a gente faz por
diversão por nós
ela falou ótimo vão fazer e ao mesmo
tempo a minha carreira no futebol
falando de futebol e escrevendo sobre o
futebol que já estava indo bem
eu tinha ganhado visibilidade por meio
de um canal esportivo grande já existiam
na internet e isso trazia algumas
mulheres para perto de mim e toda vez
que eu ia jogar bola eu postar uma foto
eu recebia muita mensagem sendo assim no
ano a gente jogar com você por favor não
tem time pra jogar eu posso só irá
assistir eu falei que estranho
chamei a cassi que hoje é a pessoa que
cuida da organização do paço a bola
junto com outras meninas
eu falei tá você acha que a gente abrir
o nosso dia de diversão pra
absolutamente qualquer mulher que quiser
praticar gratuitamente
ela vai enfrentar no dia que a gente fez
o evento apareceram cerca de 300
mulheres
a gente se olhou a gente falou é que a
gente faz agora tinha em quadra as
meninas jogaram falou tão coisa errada
porque as pessoas no brasil têm certeza
que não tem mulher querendo jogar
futebol é o que mais tem a mulher
querendo jogar futebol
só falta oportunidade então a gente viu
que o certo seria ter uma organização
oposta bola ele não funcionaria sonar
esad porque era muita mulher então a
gente decidiu fazer tudo da forma certa
e foi assim que a gente conseguiu e
consegue até hoje reúne cerca de 80
meninas semanalmente em uma lista de
espera com mais de 200 que é uma espera
que durou do dois meses mas a gente sabe
que todas essas meninas vão jogar bola
eu não posso falar do passado bola sem
falar das mulheres que fazem passar a
bola
ele não é um projeto meu ele é nosso eu
sempre falo isso pra elas
a gente faz isso e elas podem falar
muito melhor do que eu um pouco do nosso
trabalho e é por isso que optei hoje
traz um depoimento de uma das mulheres
ele é pra vocês essa mulher incrível é a
manu a tem 36 anos haja emocionou muito
e eu vou ler pra vocês
espero que amanhã eu fiquei tremendo
segurando o papel de goiânia e mora em
são paulo há nove anos desde que eu
cheguei eu passei por um período muito
difícil eu não tinha amigos família
ninguém fui me tornando uma pessoa muito
introspectiva e psicologicamente e
emocionalmente independente do meu
marido
fiquei completamente vulnerável
só faltava ele tem que me dar banho meu
casamento
a única coisa que eu tinha estava indo
muito mal
um dia eu estava na internet e eu
encontrei o passar a bola mas o dia do
meu início eu quase não fui foi por
muito pouco mas o primeiro dia eu fui
tão bem recebida que eu me senti leve de
um alívio no meu coração
o passo a bola pra mim é mais do que uma
terapia eu encontrei agora vocês nos
colocam como se fossemos realmente uma
família e isso eu encontrei em lugar
nenhum e nove anos em são paulo
meu casamento melhorou sabe eu estou
melhor
eu chego em casa sorrindo é
transformador
por exemplo agora não depende mais do
meu marido entende nem psicologicamente
nem nada
eu posso falar eu tô indo jogar bola eu
tô indo encontrar as meninas foi uma
libertação eu voltei a ver o mundo agora
são vários aprendizados como passar a
bola
o primeiro foi aprender a me ver no
espelho
o segundo mas não tão importante é a ser
muito boa no futebol
essas são algumas das minhas meninas do
paço a bola das nossas meninas são
mulheres com histórias localizações
realidades completamente distintas
dentro da cidade de são paulo
mas um único objetivo encontrar um lugar
para poder jogar futebol e se
reencontrar com outras mulheres
eu cresci num ambiente bem masculino
porque eu cresci em grupos de meninos
tanto na infância quanto na minha
adolescência eu usava as roupas do meu
irmão eu colocava boné eu prendia o
cabelo e eu falava ah eu só como os
meninos eles são muito mais legais e eu
fazendo tudo aquilo era como se eu
tivesse tentado me cabos la e esconder a
mulher que meus pais colocaram no mundo
então chegava na mesa do jantar e eu
falava assim as meninas são muito chatas
os meninos são muito mais legais porque
eu sou que nem eles sobre uma loucura
que eu tenha demorado tanto tempo para
perceber que tudo que eu fazia não era
ser como o menino estava sendo o que uma
garota tem que ser livre
quando chego não passa a bola
semanalmente e óleo para nossa quadra as
meninas jogando bola
é um outro esporte tem falta
as meninas se levantam ela se abraçam
quando ela chega se uma mulher tá mal
pelo motivo que for
todo mundo se dedica a abraçá la
a fazê la sentir melhor e isso é uma
coisa do futebol feminino aconteceu em
uma coisa muito incrível estava tendo um
campeonato oficial no leste asiático e
atleta que estava no ataque da palestina
usando um véu foi tentar um drible e o
véu caiu na disputa com a adversária que
veio pra cobrir o lance como normal ea
bola saiu imediatamente as atletas
adversários da jordânia correram pra
cobrir aquela mulher porque o jab que o
lenço que ela usa
ele é para as mulheres islâmicas a
proteção à privacidade e à moralidade
naquele momento nada foi mais importante
do que se preocupar com o outro com a
cultura do outro em como aquela mulher e
está sentindo
no meio de tanta gente no meio de um
estádio um simples ato de fair play em
que ninguém quis ganhar uma vantagem
esportivamente que é uma coisa que a
gente vê no futebol o tempo todo o
futebol feminino ele é diferente
as mulheres elas são diferentes eu acho
que justamente pela modalidade crescer
em um ambiente tão adverso tão difícil
ele é feito de empatia luta e altruísmo
porque cada uma de nós
a gente sabe o que a gente lutou e
passou pra conseguir um espaço ali é por
isso que eu quero que mulheres meninas
do brasil inteiro tenham acesso a
projetos como passar a bola porque
enquanto a gente lutar
nenhuma nenhuma menina vai ter que
pensar em ser como garoto pra fazer
apenas aquilo que ela deseja
e talvez ela demora tempo demais como eu
demorei muito obrigado
[Aplausos]